hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video von chris von basti zugesendet was
heißt how much to you really know about
pizza und ich als der ca größte pizza
liebhaber der welt ich meine leute sogar
meinen merchandise da steht das steht
auch ein leica die pizza drauf user von
de blob den pulli sollte ich vielleicht
sogar anziehen da bringt mir eventuell
ja glück ein paar sekunden später so
leute mit dem kuschlig ssten polizei
welt an geht's jetzt los mit dem qsv
marktstudie really know about the west
futemma also ich muss wirklich sagen
bevor das christ jetzt wirklich gerade
los geht die erste aussage hier schon
sehr sehr passend pizza ist einfach das
geilste essen der welt which were
stifters cd in america tourstart selling
pizza boston new york philadelphia oder
trend ich würde sagen als es geht in der
frage darum was die erste amerikanischen
stadt war die wirklich pizza verkauft
hat ich weiß nicht wieso als erstes
sonne frage gewählt wird in bezug auf
amerika und pizza verkauft und nicht
irgendwie wie überhaupt die pizza
herkommt aber ich würde sagen ich bin
mir dabei nicht wirklich sicher ich war
halt nur in new york und an jeder ecke
in den pizza laden und alles new york
pizza mäßig aufgebaut ist wie krieg ich
einfach mal new york an
ich habe es richtig alter lombardis in
new york ist credit as being the first
pizzeria in america storting becken ein
team fünf was alter in new york gibt es
einfach pizza seit 111 jahren mit pizza
change the first of trust pizza
nationwide also stuff heißt also dass so
eine gefüllte große sag ich mal mit
beispielsweise käse oder so domino slams
diese ist papa john's oder pizza hut ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung ich weiß nur
dass dominos und pizza hut derzeit
glaube ich zusammenarbeiten oder
zusammen sich geschlossen haben keine
ahnung ich also bei der new york sache
früher habe ich auch schon geraten da
eine begründung beiden total dumm ich
war new york überall beim pizzerias in
jeder großstadt sind überall pizzeria
aber hey die ersten die ein
gefüllte kruste angeboten haben als ich
muss wirklich sagen ich bin jemand der
geest keine kosten voll viele oder fast
alle von meinen freunden sagen so bist
du dumm kostet das beste aber hey ich
mag das irgendwie nicht ich mag die
kosten irgendwie nicht so gern ich weiß
nicht warum ich finde den man holt sich
aber nicht eine pizza um das zu essen
was man da drauf packt deswegen man ja
toll oder margeriten oder salami einfach
weil sich darum unterscheiden was drauf
ist und die kosten also ich meine
einfach keine kosten daher muss ich halt
leider auch wieder raten
ich würde einfach mal sagen dominos weil
die miriam ältesten erscheinen also ich
klicke mal domino
ich wusste einst von den beiden habe ich
dachte domino sie wer älter als pizza.de
might have invented pizza harte borsten
befürchteter opfer pizza whiskys taft
international national scale ja das
haben ja gesagt also irgendwie sowas wie
ein käse cruise oder so aber die haben
ist nicht erfunden aber wenn sie es
nicht erfunden haben dann hat es doch
derjenige der 200 als erstes benutzt
aber mit chicago chains credit suisse in
lenting die fdic davos nun mal nazis
pizzeria il oder - es keine ahnung ich
verstehe die frage nicht mal also wenn
ich dir google ist die tisch entweder
halten musiker oder halten
ein musikvideo oder so als chicago style
pizza oder die pizza bezeichnet man eine
us amerikanische version von pizza und
von wem ist es jetzt jedem medium ist es
rappelt in der kiste ene mene meck und
du bist weg location
ronny ist laut oppler topping in die
us-fonds dass secondos popular songs on
jens maaß extra gees
in den usa locker extra cheese ich habe
auch wieder keine ahnung
wenn ich nicht besser bestellt dann
nehme ich entweder eine hawaii die hat
übrigens ich jetzt hier wieder in und
also ich bin nackt bin ich pizza
bestellen beständigkeit entweder eine
hawaii die hat halt nur ananas und
schinken drauf oder ich es eine tonne
und die hat halt nur thunfisch drauf das
heißt und davon ist sie nicht
aufgelistet
ich würde sagen sonst eigentlich auf
keinen fall macht schluss auch auf
keinen fall also ich kenne zwar viele
leute die pizza mit pilzen essen aber
also das ist jetzt nicht das
zweitbekannteste in den usa bzw
dieses zweite schnellste zwiebeln oder
extra käse ist jetzt halt die sache ich
bin mir da überhaupt nicht sicher ist
auf jeden fall zwiebeln oder extra käse
ich glaube zwiebeln leute drücken jetzt
und es ist dumm und ich sag noch so dass
horst auf keinen fall das habe ich als
erstes raus gestrichene kacke ist es
traurig watts america series favorite
pizza topping also das was die quasi am
gar nicht drauf packen im pilze ngroup
pineapple das ist das was sie am meisten
drauf packen also an hals oder grüne
oliven da ich einfach überhaupt nicht
weiß was an zombies ist würde ich das
einfach mal anklicken des chores einfach
das nehmen was man nicht kennt ja
cording des saint paul angeles americans
liest favorite hopping was ist das jetzt
vorbei das den satellit packt sich
danach auf seine pizza es ratten bild
wie sonne sagt deller aufgeschnitten
wird ich will das gar nicht einblenden
übrigens sorry für die lichtverhältnisse
aber ich werde dir gerade beleuchtet mit
seiner lampe die einfach so rum steht
und ich habe den schirm einfach halb
abgedreht und umgedreht und jetzt
leuchtet es mich an als wenn die lampe
normal stehen würde
wird es quasi so aussehen alles aber
jetzt bin ich froh ist dass neben der
pizzeria delitzsch kevin in home alone
was ich habe den film nicht gesehen ich
wollte mir den letzten mal angucken aber
da hat eine freundin gesagt lokale film
ist ihr zu krass für dich und ich dachte
sein
ich habe den film auf jeden fall nicht
gesehen also kevin allein zu haus und
deswegen kann ich auch überhaupt nicht
sagen die pizzeria da heißt aber wir
haben alle möglichkeiten panucci de de
niro the papas oder luigis ich denke auf
jeden fall mitteln ihres oder luigis
luigis ist halt so ein typischer
pizzeria name für einen film so relativ
kurz so dass man sich da gar nicht lange
drüber nachdenkt ist wegen würde ich
sagen luigis meine damen aussteht ist
das hat die sogar noch mit der auswahl
finde einfach little niveaus da ich war
glaube ich mal in london in dem laden
medizin wie niro oder so die hatten auch
hammer pizza vielleicht hatte ich
deswegen so ein bisschen noch in my mind
the country to the first major pizza
origin also in welchem land wurden
tomaten als pizza grundlage dingens also
da ist erstens so drauf und alles
möglich genutzt italien griechenland wie
ruder indien ich glaube das ist eine
fangfrage ich denke nicht dass dass
italien sein wird allerdings habe ich
auch keinen plan was du sonst sein
könnte was soll man denn da auch googeln
wenn man tricksen will welches land zu
erwarten ob peter bürgel ich will so
fertig war gab segway fahren die ich war
ich würde sagen italien wenn gott
fackelt natürlich peru
was auch sonst bot native zur european
countries of european pietza dem den
klub majors und ms office until the
truth brodbeck von peru bei explorers da
steht doch jetzt nur dass die dass die
tomate aus peru kommt aber trotzdem sei
das italiener das als erst drauf gepackt
haben brad pitts chain of the starry
männer die livery guarantee pizza hut
domino's papa john's wird dass die genau
die gleichen möglichkeiten gefunden auch
hatte nicht weiß wohin richtig war aber
ich würde jetzt sogar wirklich sagen
pizza hut weil wir haben in köln schon
öfters mal pizza hut bestellten die
waren schnell da und ich glaube die
haben das versprochen also ich denke mal
pizza hut und es ist falsch es ist toll
- bei ihm habe ich das angebot der pizza
hut richtig
die reform ist wirklich gerade gegen den
kamin nicht persönlich und los kostet
company to end attractive pizza hut mit
headlines in 2015 vor offering rodney
king super kraftstoffs nachos hot dogs
oder gar worse nazis denke ich eher
nicht weil das käse den kosten ist das
war ja schon immer irgendwie bekannt hot
dogs in den großen ball doch ich glaube
schon nicht kompott ochs sei nichtig hot
dogs an und es ist richtig ich wusste
dass ich unseren ich wusste ist jetzt
die hinter der internationen pizza hut
in lons der hot dog fights pizza
completed masse pipping source war
schwer ist den pizza mit hot dogs und
senden wurde besten die in afrika world
pizza bergers preis oder kay leute
zwischen pizza chris okay sei laut
peters think it's es korrekt
die clique mal pizza an und wir sind
salami pizza mein leben macht keinen
sinn mehr
das war es hier vom video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe euch hat es
gefallen wenn es das getan hat lassen
eine bewertung da also daumen hoch oder
daumen runter wenn euch nicht gefallen
dann streichen wenn die kommentare test
er will wer dennoch dran
jetzt findet hier ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf klickt
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren und
verpasste keine videos mehr das ist
kostenlos es ist ein kugeln agierten
besserer mensch dadurch und hier findet
ihr irgendein anderes video eingeblendet
also irgendwas was ich schon mal hoch
bleiben habe
[Musik]